Alors Tamara, clairement, c'est
une opération de représailles
de la part de la Russie
et sûrement pas la dernière.
TAMARA ALTÉRESCO, @tamaralt
- Oui, on vient de l'entendre.
Vladimir Poutine qui a confirmé
en personne, de vive voix, et
ça, c'était devant son conseil
de sécurité que la Russie
avait lancé cette offensive
vraiment tout azimut.
C'est venu du ciel, depuis
la mer Noire, du sol, comme
attaques. Vraiment. Vraiment. Vt
pour l'Ukraine. Et il ajoute
qu'il n'hésitera pas à continuer
au cas où l'Ukraine ose attaquer
une fois de plus la Russie.
Donc, oui, il tient l'Ukraine,
ses services secrets,
responsable de l'explosion
qui a endommagé le pont
de Kertch. C'est ce grand pont,
et je crois qu'on a des images.
C'est important parce que
c'est central : c'est ce pont
qu'il avait fait construire
en 2018 pour relier la Crimée
et le territoire russe.
Donc ça, c'est un grand symbole
pour Vladimir Poutine,
de sa force et du contrôle
qu'il exerce sur la Crimée
depuis qu'il l'a annexé.
t après cette explosion
ce week-end que la réponse
de Vladimir Poutine n'allait pas
tarder. C'est certainement
un prétexte pour escalader,
comme on le voit aujourd'hui,
mais c'est pas le seul,
Brigitte. La Russie est
en train de perdre au front,
la mobilisation de centaines
de milliers d'hommes, ça ne
se passe pas comme il veut.
C'est le chaos en Russie.
- Il perd ses généraux.
- Il perd des généraux et
les remplace. Donc, les déboires
de son aont, qui
recule et qui recule sans cesse.
On en parle moins aujourd'hui,
mais c'était ça, la tendance
depuis des semaines déjà.
a choisi une fois
de plus aujourd'hui d'escalader.
Je vous dirais même de tester
encore une fois les nerfs
de l'Ukraine, des Ukrainiens,
des civils, mais du gouvernement
aussi, et la ténacité aussi
des alliés, à sav
s'ils sont encore prêts
à soutenir l'Ukraine.
- Alors, on va ent
M. Zelensky.
Don, le président Zelenskyqui ec
son cabinet, bien sûr, et qui
est aussi en attente des pays
alliés, d'aide supplémentaire
encore.
- Absolument.
- À quoi on peut s'attendre
compte tenu de ce qui vient
de se passer?
- Bien, il a passée,
une bonne partie de la journée
au téléphone, entre autres avec
Justin Trudeau, avec Joe Biden.
Et de l'ONU à l'OTAN, de l'Union
européenne à Washington,
on condamne ces attaques
brutales et, oui, on réitère
le soutien à l'Ukraine.
Mais quel genre de soutien
exactement? Zelensky a multiplié
ls à l'aide avec comme
priorité numéro un, Brigitte,
cette fois, la défense aérienne.
Il a donné l'exemp
savez, des 80 quelques missiles
qui ont été lancés sur l'Ukraine
dans les dernières,
il y en a presque la moitié qui
ont été interceptés grâce à des
systèmes de défense antimissile.
est ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'ee
à l'Occident de lui fournir
et Washington aurait accepté
aujourd'hui en fin de journée
n fournir davantage,
donc, pour protéger l'Ukraine.
Je pense que c'est la priorité
aujourd'hui. Il y aura
réunion d'urgence du G7 demain
pour discuter d'une réponse
coordonnée.Est-ce qu'on va aller
plus loin que les sanctions
pour punir la Russie de
ce qui est qualifié aujourd'hui
d'acte de terrorisme et, pour
certains, de crimes de guerre?
Donc, on va survei
Et on envoie aussi des messages
à Loukachenko, président du
Bélarus, qui se dit prêt
nt à se nt à se nt à se nt à see
côte à côte avec la Russie.
On ne sait pas avec combien
de soldats, mais il prépare
le terrain pour l'arrivéede beas
de soldats russes sur
son territoire.
st en cours
depuis sept mois, rappelons-le.
Merci beaucoup, Tamara.
- Au revoir.